but a nipple just seems sexy like a
little
bit
[Music]
i'm pretty crazy i'm about to answer the
internet and i'm going to be honest with
you i'm never going to be as good as my
friends my friends are [ __ ] awesome
when they do this you're pretty [ __ ]
good
i wouldn't worry about it are there more
doors or wheels in the world that's the
big one that went viral recently oh for
real yeah
wheels on the car but usually two to
four doors
you also got little things like the gas
tank door but then you got twitch oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] i mean god damn it i love
when you redo like i bet this kid one
time that i go uh if the if the seahawks
win i'll give you 200 but if the rams
when i get to cut you your hair and he
didn't think it through he thought i
wanted to cut his hair he was 10 years
old and i [ __ ] this kid's head up the
first thing i did i cut his bangs like
simple jack and he looked at me and he
goes does it look cool
no [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] you up so that's
what you got that's why you got to do
the math that's how you're going to
demand this i'm going i'm going wheels
would you [ __ ] kelly ripa if it had to
be a threesome with regis philbin is he
still alive no i'll rest in peace but he
was alive uh by the way yes i would
definitely [ __ ] kelly rippo with a
threesome with regis i met regis one
time and he was so goddamn charming he
came dude i was doing rachel ray and he
came up and he goes bert
a lot of famous birds i know a bert
baccarat i know a bert he was so much
fun that in a threesome you know he goes
he's going for the back door
looks like i'll take the mouth we'll
call it leaky submarine there we go
we're the panicky sailors that gotta
plug up all their holes
yeah i'm taking the threads
that was on deck
i did have a threesome and it was not
that fun
no it's just like it was like awkward
and i was dating one of the girls and
then she was like you're gonna feel
different about me tomorrow and i was
like no i'm not and then i did well
is there any athlete you would be okay
with your girlfriend [ __ ] you mean my
wife yeah aaron rodgers
cinco de mayo may 5th at the greek if my
wife wants to have sex with aaron
rodgers she's in if you've got 10 000 a
day for every day you didn't masturbate
how many days could you last you know i
actually did this when i was working on
travel channel i thought
i stopped masturbating on the road and
it turns out i can go two weeks and then
my body starts shaking and humming like
what i wanted to do is i wanted to get
back to having a nocturnal emissions
you know
yeah well i wonder what dream i wanted i
could because i could get the white
dream up and running but then the orgasm
part yeah and so i was like i just got
to stop masturbating and it didn't
happen what percentage of the internet
porn do you think you've seen
this is so funny
can i tell you something
i thought of something the other day
that i can't find on in porn on the
internet and i thought huh
i out fought the internet
i can't say it there's a young lady in
this room and i will not see that person
not count
i wanted to see
a woman put her nipple in a dude's
dickle
and i can't find him i
if you're in i want you to see a woman
put her nipple in a dude's dick you see
titty [ __ ] it's so not hot right
you're like
i wanted to see that and i couldn't find
it and i looked high and low
and by the way i also use the verb is
that a person that would do that do
because they don't use urethra they
don't use they're sounding that's where
they put a rotten dude's dick
yeah that's [ __ ] up but a nipple just
seemed sexy like a little bit
couldn't find it
so i would say i've seen a lot
if there was a snail following you for
the rest of your life
if you
touched it
am i [ __ ]
if there was a snail following you for
the rest of your life and if you touched
it you'd die how long could you survive
this is another internet classic you
mean it has like a thirst for blood
wants to kill you it can it can like it
will go to the airport it will hop on a
plane it knows you know where you are
but it's got to get to you and obviously
it just moves at the pace of the snail
oh never i never it would never touch me
i moved way too fast i moved and by the
way i just had this conversation with my
wife in the car driving here she's like
you need to slow the [ __ ] down but if i
slow down then my brain starts working
and so i don't slow down at all if you
keep moving your brain doesn't get to go
one day it goes black and you die
if you could party with one sports team
from history who would it be i'm gonna i
know that i'm gonna get [ __ ] hate for
saying this but i think it would be
like the 91 92 miami university team
with michael irving
[ __ ]
warren staff
[ __ ] bro i would party with them
i go to i go to uncle luke's house
notorious b.i.g will walk in i'd have
one girl on this nipple one girl in this
nipple working the work in the jab worn
sad would high five me go big dog i go
that's how i do it if you had to have a
threesome with one male actor who would
it be brad pitt
brad pitt and i would and i would just
watch him i'd just watch him
i'd be like
[Music]
put it put your nipple in there
isn't that crazy that that's never been
done that seems like we can probably
find that it's definitely because it is
i remember reading in cosmopolitan once
that it was like sex tips for women and
one was put your pinky in his [ __ ]
well you can find that you can find that
you can find that you can find that yeah
you can find that you can find that i
found it i found it
only only two videos of a girl putting
her tongue in a dude's [ __ ] only two
videos it's the same girl it's the same
girl she's gonna she's getting her she's
got a ring right here it's the same girl
and uh and uh would you do that i don't
know i can't even [ __ ] find it i
don't think it's a real thing and i'm
not pitching it to my wife my wife's not
gonna be like he's not putting anything
in any hat look leanne's pretty meat and
potatoes if you want to [ __ ] we [ __ ]
that's it
why would i want to be tied up you got
heart problems i ain't gonna let you die
[ __ ] it's one thing if your kid's
walking in on you having sex there's
another thing of dad's in a leather
zipper mask
if you were dating a 10 but at night she
turned into a hideous creature
you still
[Music]
all i will say is very respectfully my
wife is beautiful
but at 52 when she sleeps sometimes her
face just falls over like dude
and you're just looking at her going
how do we get this room darker
so yeah i'd be cool with dating a model
if she turned into piano apple at night
if you want apple beautiful
what's your number one karaoke song
without a doubt uh sister christian
it's my favorite it's my favorite you're
motoring
are you a victory
um yes i was i was and then what
happened is as a comic i would lose my
voice doing karaoke and i'd be useless
for the rest of the shows would you
rather have your dick as a hose or nose
or your nose as a dick um
i by the way it brings up there's a
horrible dan akron movie where he has a
dick as a nose
yeah he does yeah yeah yeah have you
ever not seen it chevy chase is in it uh
dan aykroyd john i think john candy he
just has a [ __ ] penis it's a penis on
his nose and it's google it it's [ __ ]
and it i just talked to someone about
this movie the other day it's the most
disturbing movie i've ever seen because
it's
no it just it gets bigger and longer and
uh so i'd take a nose as a dick but then
i'd be smelling my balls all day
by the way i'd just be walking around
like this
[Music]
you'd fart you'd pull your pants down
and just [ __ ] out your ass
i go i guess i gotta go with a little
bit of a take a little slice of a hole
on my just like a little urethra right
there and then piss out my nose
shout out to bert kreischer he's the
absolute best in the game his answer to
the internet is always money if you like
this one go back and watch the old one
and make sure that you subscribe so you
never miss an episode click the bell
button for notifications and we'll see
you next week